mark is with us in Las Vegas hey Mark
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
hey what's up boy we're trying to figure
out whether or not we want to help our
daughter get out of her student loans
she she is a dentist now you know thank
god she's been practicing for about two
months and but Dave I'm telling us she
really really wrecked up student loans
during her eight years of college you
know she was jetting here and jetting
there and spending a lot of money but
she's a dentist you know but this
interest folding her grand about three
about three eighty okay yeah pretty good
guess almost like I've done this the and
and what's she making now well she's
making you know she's making some she's
making some darn good money right now
what you know makin to be honest with
you Dave I don't know what she's making
but I seen the payments that she's been
making you know she consolidated is
she's like this anymore pardon me if she
is worried about this as you are I don't
think she is data but I'm not help you
know you know I help people that are
heading in the right direction but she's
not worried about this she's not headed
in the right direction she's still under
the stupid illusion this is okay so uh
you know you're all tore up about this
and she's the one that should be all
tore up about it
no I'm torn up about it because I have
always my whole life even when I was a
kid I was very very fiscally
conservative that saved my money
no no worth I just we're gonna we're
gonna retire with I just we ran the
numbers while I was
on hold and we're gonna retire about 1.6
million in the black good for you well
done sir
proud of you listen interested eight I
know you know but she doesn't she
doesn't and so you know let me tell you
what's gonna happen if you reach over
and pay off four thousand for the
student loan debt you know what she's
gonna do she's gonna go buy a practice
and go half-million dollars in debt
because she doesn't hate that I wanted
to learn to hate debt and then I'll help
her cuz the debt is not the problem it's
the symptom and she's got to learn to
hate it like you hate it if she calls me
up exasperated and sighing and stressed
like you are then I would say you know
if you want to throw you want to match
her and say alright baby doll you put
150 on this I put 150 on this I'll match
you whatever you do which might be
something you could offer to her say
I'll match you dollar for dollar you
want to do that sounds good to know yeah
because I want her heading in the right
direction I don't want to try to coach
somebody to go do something that doesn't
want to do it and she's not worried
about it because all these dentists they
you know there's a dadgum stupid they
think this is okay and it's not okay
it's ridiculous it's absolutely
ridiculous and so it's got to be cleaned
up and the first thing she should do is
use her newfound income and keep living
like a college student like you and I
would do live on nothing and clean this
mess up as fast as possible
so let's put her to the test sit down
and tell her this is stressing me out I
feel so bad for you I wish you were
stressed out about you as I am about you
and here's what I'm willing to do I'm
willing to get I'm willing to match you
dollar for dollar and see if you got
anything inside of you that's gonna make
you get this paid off see if you got
some of my DNA in your kiddo and I'm
gonna call her out if I'm her dad and
then if she does nothing you do nothing
but you match your dollar for dollar if
you want to do that you got the money
hundred fifty won't hurt you a bit you
can it'll hurt you emotionally but you
got plenty of money you've done a great
job congratulations
but you can't make other people behave
even your own kids and you can't want it
for them more than they want it and have
a successful interaction it won't work
so lover well give her some fatherly
advice by the way you're worth a whole
lot more and she is so it'd be worth
taking counsel from a guy like you I
mean you're smarter than whip you got a
million six doing everyday millionaire
so I that's what I would do I would
match her and I would encourage her and
coach her up and see if you can get her
moving and then you know then that'd be
the biggest blessing ever happened to
her